III has come and gone and now we know
about a bunch of hot games will be
playing over the next year or so but if
you're an Xbox Live Gold member and want
to know what you can play in July for
free I've got you covered
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to be the first to know about the
games with gold lineup every month
first up for Xbox one is grow up the
sequel to grow home but the robot is
still climbing and jumping around
collecting all sorts of things but he'll
obtain a bunch of new powers this time
around like using a jet pack or rolling
into a Metroid style ball grow up will
be available all month long
in June games with gold brought us
speedrunners and this month we've got a
similar game called run bow your goal in
this platformer racer is to be the first
to reach the end of the level but the
trick is that the background is
constantly changing colors meaning you
don't have to worry about any obstacles
that blend in ronbo is making its Xbox
one debut on July 16th and it'll be
available through August 15th on the 360
side you can get your hands on Kane and
Lynch to the pair split up at the end of
the first game but reunite in Dog Days
to smuggle some guns into Africa you'll
mostly be playing as Lynch but you can
bring a friend for co-op and have them
step into Kane's shoes it'll be
available July 1st through the 15th and
if you want something more kid-friendly
you can also grab Lego Pirates of the
Caribbean Jack Sparrow Captain Barbossa
and all your favorites are here in brick
form you can control them through the
events of the first four movies
collecting studs and building all sorts
of contraptions lego pirates will be
available July 16th through the 31st and
remember both of these can also be
played on Xbox one thanks to backwards
compatibility and those are your free
games with gold for July 2017 you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles over at
GameSpot and if you want to keep up with
all of our top stories then why not grab
the official game spot now app available
on iOS and Android
[Music]